If you're publishing in the scientific literature,
you need to be aware of the problem of predatory
open-access journals.
Predatory open-access journals are bogus journals
that are exploiting the open-access model
to make money.
Open-access journals are a great idea.
The idea is that authors pay publishing fees
so that journals can make the full text of
articles freely available to everyone.
The PLOS journals, Public Library of Science
journals, are shining examples of this open-access
publishing model.
When it's done with integrity, open-access
publishing is fantastic.
But, because money is exchanging hands, this
has opened the floodgates for the creation
of bogus journals which exist solely to collect
money from authors, not to publish high-quality
research.
Jeffrey Beall, a librarian at the University
of Colorado, Denver, has been a leader in
calling out this practice and keeping lists
of bad publishers and bad journals.
Another leader in exposing this whole problem
is the journalist John Bohannon.
He ran a sort of sting operation that he wrote
about in Science in 2013.
What he did was he submitted an obviously
flawed bogus paper.
He describes it as he did a scientific version
of Mad Libs so that he could come up with
255 slightly different versions of the same
paper where he took molecule X from lichen
species Y inhibits the growth of cancer cell
Z.
He created a whole bunch of different papers
just substituting different molecules and
species and cancer cells.
And the papers had obvious flaws.
Any scientist, no matter how schooled, should
have been able to look at figure 1 and know
that this paper was problematic.
He submitted this to open-access journals,
many of which he suspected to be predatory
journals.
And indeed, of 255 where he got a decision
back, 157 of those journals accepted that
paper.
It was only rejected by 98.
In fact, 82 percent of the publishers on Jeffrey
Beall's list actually accepted that paper.
So, John Bohannan was able to show that there
is this huge suite out there of predatory
journals and they are willing to accept anything
for money.
Along with the report, Science published a
map that shows the location of publishers,
editors, and their bank accounts, color-coded
by acceptance or rejection of the paper.
The locations were derived from IP address
traces within the raw headers of e-mails,
WHOIS registrations, and bank invoices for
publication fees.
India emerged as the world's largest base
for fee-charging open-access publishing (64
publishers), and over 90% of them accepted
the paper.
The United States is the next largest base,
with 29 publishers accepting the paper and
26 rejecting it.
In Africa, Nigeria has the largest number,
of which 100% accepted the paper.
All evidence shows us that these predatory
journals are greatly on the rise.
There was a 2015 paper in BMC Medicine that
tracked predatory journals from 2010 to 2014.
You can see it's growing exponentially.
Pay attention to that red line on top.
That's the total number of predatory journals.
They estimated that in 2014, there were about
8,000 active predatory journals.
In 2010, these journals published about 53,000
articles.
That was up to 420,000 articles published
in these predatory journals in 2014.
These are probably all or most of poor quality.
Authors paid an average article processing
charge of US$178 per article, so it's a money-making
scam.
That same paper, they also share that this
affects all scientific disciplines.
You can see in this graph here that no scientific
discipline was safe from this practice.
In 2013, Declan Butler this checklist in Nature
to help you vet journals, to make sure that
you're being careful to not submit to one
of these predatory journals.
He suggested that author should check that
the publisher provides full, verifiable contact
information.
You want the full address of the publisher
to be available.
You also want to check that the journal's
editorial board lists actual experts with
full affiliations, not just made-up people.
You might even want to contact them and ask
them about their experience with the publisher
because there are known instances when people's
names have been borrowed and just stuck on
these websites without the person's permission.
You want to check that the journal prominently
displays its policy for author fees.
Open-access journals do charge fees, but you
want to make sure that these policies are
clearly described on their website.
If they're not, that's a suspicious sign.
Be wary of spam e-mail invitations.
You will get a lot of these e-mails that ask
you to submit to journals or to become an
editorial board member or to speak at a conference.
You can tell that these are spam if you look
carefully.
Always go to the journal's website and make
sure that the articles that they are publishing
are high-quality articles.
Check that a journal's peer-review process
is clearly described.
Make sure that they are actually doing peer
review, and try to find out whether a journal's
claimed impact factor is correct.
There is a trend now where these predatory
journals are making up bogus metrics.
They have names like the universal impact
factor, UIF, or the global impact factor,
GIF, or the journal impact factor, JIF.
These are all popular but bogus metrics made
up by predatory journals.
They sound a lot like the real thing, so be
careful not to get sucked into that.
There are lists people publish of supposedly
legitimate open-access journals.
The lists are not perfect, but at least the
journals listed there have gone through some
vetting.
You might want to check before submitting,
you can check with the Directory of Open Access
Journals or the Open Access Scholarly Publishers
Association.
You can check there and make sure that the
journal you're submitting to is listed there.
Finally, use common sense.
If something looks fishy, if it looks like
spam, it probably is.
So just be careful and be aware of these predatory
journals.